The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right.
Today we start a new
section of data structures.
This is going to be
two lectures long,
so this week succinct data
structures, where the goal is
to get really small space.
And first thing to do is to
define what "small" means.
Most succinct data
structures are also static,
although there are a
few that are dynamic.
We'll be focusing here on
static data structures.
And so in general,
the name of the game
is taking a data
structure that you're
familiar with-- we're going
to talk about essentially two
today.
One is binary tries,
which has the killer
application of doing binary
suffix trees in particular.
So it could be a
compressed try, whatever.
But we'll assume hear
the alphabet is binary.
A lot of this has
been generalized
to larger alphabets.
I'll tell you a
little bit about that.
But to keep it
simple in lecture,
I'm going to stick
to a binary alphabet.
And another data structure
we're going to look at
is a bit vector,
so n bits in a row.
And you want to do
interesting operations,
like find the i-th 1
bit in constant time.
These are things
that are easy to do
in linear space, where linear
space means order and words.
Like if you want
to implement a try,
you have a pointer at
every node, two pointers
at every node, that's easy.
Bit vectors you could store an
array of where all the 1s are.
And so it's easy
to do linear space,
but linear space is not optimal.
And there are three
senses of small space
that we'll be going for.
The best version is implicit.
An implicit data structure means
you use the very optimum number
of bits, plus a constant.
But here, we're focusing
on bits, not words.
And if you translate a
linear word data structure,
and words is order
n times w bits,
to store something
like an n-bit vector,
you should really only use
order n bits, not order nw bits.
Now, what would
be ideal is if you
used n bits plus a constant.
The plus a constant
is essentially
because sometimes the optimum
number is not an integer.
And it's hard to store a
non-integer number of bits,
so you add a constant.
I mean, I wouldn't mind too much
if you added order log n bits
or something.
But typically, the
goal here is constant.
Sometimes you can
really get zero.
But the next best thing would
be a succinct data structure,
where the goal is to get opt
plus little o of opt bits.
So the key here is to get a
constant factor of 1 in front.
And then the worst thing in this
regime is still pretty good.
It's order opt bits.
So for example, if you're
storing an n-bit vector,
if you use order n bits,
that's still better
than order nw bits.
Usually, compact is a
savings of at least a factor
of w over what you'd normally
call a linear space data
structure.
So this is the big
savings, factor w.
But there's a constant here.
Sometimes you like to get rid
of that constant, make it 1.
And it's not so bad
if you have, say,
another square root of
n or something little o
of n bits of extra space.
But of course, the ideal would
be to have no extra space,
and that's implicit.
Now, it's a little confusing.
I usually call this area
succinct data structures
to mean all three.
But the middle one
is called succinct.
That's typically the goal
is to go for succinct,
because implicit is
very hard, and compact
is kind of like a
warm-up towards succinct.
So this is the usual
goal in the middle.
And we're going to do
this for binary tries,
and rank and select.
So let me tell you a little
bit about what's known.
Oh, sorry.
One quick example.
You've seen implicit
data structures.
You may have even heard this
term in the context of heaps.
Binary heaps are an example
of a dynamic implicit data
structure.
They achieve this bound.
They have no extra space
in the appropriate model.
And another one would
be a sorted array.
Sorted array supports
binary search.
You can't really update it, so
it's a static search structure.
It achieves the
optimal number of bits.
You're just storing the data.
And usually, implicit data
structures just store the data,
though sometimes they reorder
the data in interesting ways,
like sorting.
A sorted array is one way
to reorder your data items.
So here's a short survey.
This is definitely
not exhaustive,
but it covers a bunch
of the main results.
So one place where this
area really got started--
well, there are a
few places, actually.
My academic father,
one of my PhD advisors,
Ian Munro is sort of one of
the fathers of this field.
And he started looking at
specific data structures
at the very early days.
And one of the
problems he worked on
was dynamic search trees.
So if you want to do
static search trees,
you can just store the items
in a sorted array, easy log n
search, no extra space.
What if you want to do
inserts and deletes also
in log n time per operation,
just like a regular search
tree, but you want
to do it implicitly?
Now, this is tricky.
And there's an old
result that would
let you get log squared
per update and query, which
essentially encoded--
you can't afford
pointers at all here.
But the idea was to
encode the pointers
by permuting enough items.
If you take, say, log n
items, then the permutations
among them is roughly
log n, log log n bits.
And so you can encode bits by
just permuting pairs of items.
And so you could read a pointer
in like log n operations,
you end up with log squared.
And then Ian Munro got
down to a little bit less
than log squared.
And then there's a
series of improvements
over the last several years.
And the final result is log
n worst case insert, delete,
and predecessor.
And this is by
Franceschini and Grossi.
And furthermore,
it's cache oblivious,
so you can get log base
b of n cache oblivious.
So this has been pretty
much completely solved.
Implicitly, you can
do all the good things
we know how to do
with search trees.
Now, this is not trying to solve
the predecessor problem using
Van Emde Boas and such tricks.
That's, I believe, open.
But for a basic log n
performance, it's solved.
Before this got solved,
another important problem
is essentially the
equivalent of hashing.
So you want a
succinct dictionary.
You want to be able to do--
now, this is going to
be static, so there's
no insert and delete.
It's just, is this
item in the dictionary?
So I have a universe of size u.
I have n items in
the dictionary.
So the first question is, what
is the optimal number of bits?
And this is actually usually
very easy to compute.
You just take, what are the
set of possible structures
you're trying to
represent, which
is n items out of a
universe of size u?
How many different
ways are there
to have n items in a
universe of size u?
Come on.
It's easy combinatorics.
Somebody?
AUDIENCE: Log u of n.
ERIK DEMAINE: Log u--
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
That's how many
bits you'll need.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
Log u choose n is the
number of bits you'll need.
The number of different
possibilities is u choose n.
You take log base 2 of that,
that's how many bits you'll
need to represent this.
Now, this is not
necessarily an integer,
because it's got a log.
That's why we would
have plus order
1 if we were doing implicit.
It's not known how
to do implicit.
It's known how to
do succinct, so this
is going to be plus
little o of that thing.
And actually, I have
the explicit bound.
Eraser.
I don't know how
exciting this is,
but you get to know
how little o it is.
Log log n squared over log n.
So this is slightly
smaller, so this is
roughly something like u log n.
It depends.
If n is small, this
is like u log n.
If n is big, this is like--
sorry, n log u, I should say.
You can always encode a
dictionary using n log u bits.
Just for every item, you
specify the log u bits.
But when n is big,
close to u, then you
can just use a bit
vector and use u bits.
And so this is little
o of n, so it's always
smaller than whatever
you're encoding over here.
It's only slightly smaller than
n, log log n squared over log
n, but it's a little o of 1.
And that's I believe
the best known.
So this is Brodnik and Munro,
and then improved by Pagh.
And the point is you get
constant time membership query.
In general, the
name of the game is
you want to do
the queries you're
used to doing in something
like a dictionary, same amount
of time, but with less space.
OK.
Next one is-- maybe
I'll go over here--
binary try, which is what
we're going to work on today.
There's various results
on this, but sort
of one of the main ones
is by Munro and Raman.
Again, now this is a little
harder of a question.
How many binary tries
on n nodes are there?
The answer, I will tell you,
is the nth Catalan number,
which is a quantity
we've seen before.
2n choose n over n plus 1.
As we mentioned last time,
this is roughly 4 to the n.
This is kind of interesting.
We saw the Catalan number
in a different context,
which is we were doing
indirection and using
lookup tables at the bottom on
all rooted trees on n nodes.
Number of rooted trees on n
nodes was also Catalan number.
This is a different
concept, binary tries.
If you've ever taken
a combinatorics class,
you see Catalan numbers
all over the place.
There's a zillion different
things, all of them
the number of them
is Catalan number.
And we will actually use that
equivalence between binary
tries and rooted trees at
the end of today's lecture.
So you'll see why
they're the same number.
OK.
So we take log of
that, that's 2n bits.
So you need 2n bits to
represent a binary try.
And indeed, you can achieve
2n plus little o of n bits.
So that's a succinct
data structure.
And our goal will be to be
able to do constant time
traversal of the tree, so left
child, right child, parent.
And for fun, another
operation we might want to do
is compute the size of
the current subtree.
Again, think of a suffix tree.
You start at the
root and you want
to be able to go
along the left child
every time you have a 0
bit in your query string.
You want to go to
the right child
every time you have a 1 bit.
Parent we don't really
need, but why not?
And then subtree
size would tell us,
how many matches
are there below us?
You could count either the
number of nodes below you
or the number of
leaves below you.
It's roughly the same
for a compact try.
And so this lets you
do substring searches.
And we'll actually talk more
about that next lecture,
how to actually do
a full suffix tree.
But this is a component
of a binary suffix
tree that has the
same performance
but uses optimal
amount of space.
And this is a big motivator
originally for doing compact
or succinct data structures.
At University of Waterloo,
they were doing this new OED
project, where Oxford
English Dictionary was
trying to go online or digital.
And this concept of
having a CD-ROM that
could have an entire
dictionary on it was crazy.
And CD-ROMs were
really slow, so you
don't want to just scan the
entire CD to do a search.
You want to be able to
do a search for arbitrary
substrings.
That's what suffix
trees let you do.
But you really can't
afford much space.
And so that was the motivation
for developing these data
structures back in the day.
Things are a lot easier now.
Space is cheaper.
But still, there's always going
to be some giant thing that you
need to store that if you want
to store a data structure,
you really can't
afford much space.
Cool.
So that's static.
There is a dynamic version.
It's a more recent result
from just a few years ago.
You can do constant time,
insert, and delete of a leaf.
And you can do a
subdivision of an edge.
These are operations
we saw for dynamic LCA.
So same operations
as dynamic LCA,
you can do these
in constant time
and still maintain
the succinct binary
try representation,
where you can do
all these traversal operations.
So we won't cover that.
We will cover the
static version today.
Then that's for binary alphabet.
Let me tell you what's
known about larger alphabet.
This is a problem I
worked on a while ago,
though our result is
no longer the best.
So here, it's a
little complicated.
But the number of tries,
number of k-ary tries,
so k is now the size
of the alphabet,
is kn plus 1 choose
n over kn plus 1.
And so it's succinct,
meaning we can
achieve log of that plus
little o of that bits.
And the queries
we can achieve are
constant time,
child with label i,
and parent, and subtree size.
So we can do all the things
we were able to do before.
The analog of left
child and right child
now is I have a character
in my pattern, p,
and I want to know which
child has that label.
So it's not the same as finding
the i-th child of a node.
The edges are labeled by
their letter in the alphabet,
and you can achieve that.
We had an earlier result
that achieved like log log
or something, and then finally
it was brought down to constant
by Farzan and Muno.
So couple more.
Why don't I just
mention what they are?
It's getting a little tedious.
There's a lot of other things
you might want to store.
You can store
succinct permutations,
although there are some
open problems here.
So you want to store
a permutation using
log n factorial bits,
plus little o of n.
If you want to achieve
succincts, the best known--
oh, and the interesting
query is you
want to be able to do the k-th
power of your permutation,
so see where an item
goes after k steps.
Best query known for that
is log n over log log
n if you want succinct.
If you only want
compact, then it's
known how to do constant time.
So an interesting open
question is, can you achieve
succinct constant time queries?
If you relax either, then
it's known how to do it.
There's a generalization
of this to functions,
where one of those results is
known, the other one isn't.
You can try to do
Abelian groups.
There are finite Abelian groups.
There aren't too
many different ones,
and you can represent
an entire Abelian group
on n items using log n
bits, which is pretty crazy,
order log n bits.
And you can represent an item
in that group in log n bits
and do multiplication,
inverse, and equality testing.
There's other results on
graphs, which I won't get into.
Those are a little
harder to state.
And then another interesting
case is integers.
So you want to store
an integer and you
want to be able to increment
and decrement the integer.
And you want to do as few
bit operations as possible.
Worst case, for
example, if you have
lots of 1s in your bit
string, you do an increment,
you don't want to pay linear
costs, linear number of bit
updates to do it.
And so you can achieve
implicit, so just
a constant number of
extra bits of space.
If I have an n-bit
integer, then I
can do an increment
or a decrement
in order log n bit reads,
and constant bit writes.
And this is Raman and Munro
from a couple years ago.
So this is pretty good.
Of course, ideal would be
to do a constant number of--
well, a constant number
of bit reads or writes
would be optimal, I guess.
I personally would be
interested in getting
a constant number of
word reads and writes.
But that's an open
problem, I believe.
So there's only
order n bit reads.
If they were all
consecutive, that
would be a constant
number of word reads,
but they're kind of spread out.
It'd be nice to get constant
number of word operations.
So that's a quick
survey of what's known.
Let's do some actual
data structures now.
So we're going to be focusing
on this synced binary tries.
And we're going to do
two versions of it.
One of them is level order.
And the other will use
a balanced parenthesis
representation.
So let's start with
the level order one.
This is very easy.
So I'm going to just loop over
the nodes in my try in level
order, so level by
level, and write one bit
to say whether there's
a left child and one bit
to say whether
there's a right child.
Let's do a little example.
So here is a binary try.
And I'm going to write
a bit string for it.
So first, I'm going to
look at the top level.
I have the node A. It has a left
child of B, right child of C,
so I write 1, 1.
And this corresponds to
B. This corresponds to C.
OK.
Then next level is B.
It has no left child
and it has a right child, which
is D. I'm just writing down
the labels so I don't get lost.
Then we have node C, which has
a left child and a right child,
E and F. Then we have node
D, which has no left child.
It has a right
child, which is G.
Node E has no children.
Node F has no children.
Node G has no children.
OK.
So there is a 2n-bit string.
This is obviously
2n bits for n nodes,
so this is one way to prove
there's at most four to the n
tries.
And well, we'll talk
about how useful it is.
I want to give you
another representation
of the same thing, which
is if we take these nodes
and add on--
wherever there's
an absent leaf, I'm
going to add what we call an
external node, as you sometimes
see in data structures books.
One way to represent a
null pointer, say, oh,
there's a node there
that has no children.
This unifies things
a little bit,
because now every
node either has
two children or no children.
Another way to think
about the same thing.
And it turns out if you look
at this bit string and add a 1
in front--
so I'll put this
one in parentheses--
then what this is
encoding is just
for every node in level
order, are you a real node
or are you an external node?
Are you an internal node
or an external node?
A here is internal.
B is internal.
C is internal.
This is an external node.
Then this is internal,
internal, internal.
Then external, G, external,
external, external, external,
external, external.
The zeros correspond
to external nodes
because those are
absent children.
So same thing.
So I'll write equivalently, 1
equals an internal node and 0
equals an external node.
Of course, to do this,
we need one more bit.
And I'm going to take
this view primarily,
because it's a little
easier to work.
It doesn't really make
much of a difference,
just shifts
everything over by 1.
And I'd like to write
down the indices here,
so we have 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7 into this array.
Because now our challenge
is all right, great.
We've represented a binary try.
But we want to be able
to do constant time,
left child, right child, parent.
We're not going to be
able to do subtree size.
Level order is really not
good for subtree size.
But left child, right
child, and parent
we can do in constant time.
And the reason that we
can do it in constant time
is because there's
a nice lemma, kind
of analogous to binary heaps.
So the claim is if we look
at the i-th internal node,
so for example C is the
third internal node, so
internal node number 3, then
we look at positions 2 times 3,
and 2 times 3 plus 1, so
6 and 7 in this array.
And we get the two children
E and F. So that worked.
6 and 7 are E and F.
Or this one would be the
fourth internal node.
D is the fourth internal node.
And so at positions 8 and 9
should be this external node
and G. 8 is an external node.
9 is g.
So it works.
This is a lemma.
You can prove it pretty
easily by induction on i.
So the idea is,
well, if you look
at let's say the
i-th internal node
and the i minus first
internal node, this one
has two left children.
Don't know whether they're
internal or external.
Between them-- they're
on the same level
and we're in level order,
so anything in between here
is an external node.
So they have no
children, which means
if you look at
the children of i,
they're going to appear
right after the children of i
minus 1, because
we're level order.
So we have these two guys.
The next nodes at this level
are going to be these two guys.
So this one appeared at 2i
minus 2, and 2i minus 1.
This one will appear
at 2i and 2i plus 1.
This is if i and i minus
1 are on the same level,
but it also works if
they're in different levels.
So if I'm i minus 1 is the
last node on its level,
again it's going to have two
children here, which will be
the last nodes on this level.
And then right after that
will come the children of i,
again at position
2i and 2i plus 1.
OK.
So that's essentially the
proof that this works out.
There's lots of ways to
see why this is true,
but I think I'll
leave it at that.
OK.
So this is good news.
It says if we have the
i-th internal node,
we can find the left
and the right children.
But these are in different
namespaces, right?
On the one hand, we're
counting by internal nodes.
On the other hand, we're
counting by position
in the array, which
is counting position
by internal and external nodes.
This counts both 0's and 1's.
This only counts 1's.
So we need a mechanism for
translating between those two
worlds, translating between
indices that only count
1's and indices that
count 0's and 1's.
And this is the idea
of rank and select.
So in general, if I
have a string of n bits,
I want to be able to compute
the rank of a bit, which
is the number of 1's at
or before position i.
So I'm given a
position like 6 and I
want to know how
many 1's are there up
to 6, which would be 5
in the full array here.
Or I'm given a query like
8, number of 1's is 6 up
to position 8.
And then the inverse
of rank is select,
which gives you the
position of the j-th 1 bit.
So this lets you translate
between these two worlds
of counting just the 1's, which
is rank, or going to the j-th 1
bit, that's select.
So this lets you compute
the left child as just
being at position
twice the rank,
because the rank tells
you this value i, which
is which internal node are you.
That's your rank.
You multiply by 2 and that was
the position of the left child.
Right child is going
to be that plus 1.
Parent is going to use select.
So if we want the parent of i,
this is going to be select of i
over 2 with a floor.
So that's just the inverse
of left and right child.
If I divide by 2 and take
the floor, I get rid of that
plus 1, I get the rank.
And then I do select, sub 1,
and that's the inverse of rank.
So that lets me implement.
If I have rank and select in
constant time, now I can do
left child, right child,
parent in constant time.
The remaining challenge is,
how do I do rank and select?
And that's what we're
going to do next.
Any questions about
that before we go on?
All right.
So now we do real
data structures.
This is going to be some integer
data structures, some fun
stuff.
It's going to use some
techniques we know,
but in a different setting,
because now our goal is
to really minimize space.
We're going to use
indirection and lookup
tables in a new kind of way.
These are going to be
word RAM data structures.
I want to do both rank and
select in constant time.
And the amount of space
I have is little o of n.
I want succinct.
And I'm going to
store the bit vector.
So then in addition
to the bit vector, all
I'm allowed for rank and
select is little o of n space.
That's the cool part.
So rank is one of the first
succinct data structures.
It's by Jacobson, 1989.
So a first observation is, what
can we do with a lookup table?
Suppose I wanted to
store all the answers,
but I can't afford much space.
Well, let's do sort
of a worksheet.
If I had space x, or if I looked
at all bit strings of length
x and then I wanted to store
them, that's going to cost--
or store a lookup
table for each of them,
it's going to
cost-- well, there's
2 to the x different bit
strings of that length.
Then for each of them, I have
to store all possible answers
to rank and select queries.
So there's order x
different queries.
You could query every bit.
And then for each of them, I
have to write down an answer.
So this is going to be log x
bits, because the answer is
a value between 0 and
x minus 1, so it takes
log x bits to write it down.
So this is how much
space it's going
to be to store the answer for
all bit strings of length x.
So what should I set x to?
I'd like this to
be little o of n,
so anything that's a
little bit less than log n
is going to be OK.
And in particular, 1/2 log
n is a good enough choice.
If we use 1/2 log
n bits, this is
going to be root
n, log n log log
n, which is little o of n,
quite small as succinct data
structures go.
We're going to use
more space than root n.
The point is, if
we could get down
to bit strings of logarithmic
size, we'd be done.
But we have a bit
string of linear size.
So how do we reduce it?
Something like indirection.
So the funny thing here is we're
going to do indirection twice,
kind of recursively, but
stopping after two levels.
The first level
of indirection is
going to reduce things
down to size log squared.
So we're going to
take our n bit string,
divide into chunks of
size log squared n,
so there's n over
log squared n chunks.
They look something like
this, log squared n.
And the idea is right now
we're trying to just do rank,
so rank number of 1's at
or before a given position.
So what I'm going to do is that
each of these vertical bars,
I'm going to store the
cumulative rank so far.
Why log squared?
Basically because this
is what I can afford.
To store that cumulative
rank is log n bits.
I mean, this rank is
going to get very big.
By the end, it will
have most of the 1 bits,
so it could be
potentially linear.
So I'm going to need log
n bits to write that down.
But how many of these
vertical bars are there?
Well, only n over log
squared n of them.
So I have n over log squared
n things I need to write down.
Each of them is log n bits.
So do some cancellation.
This cancels with that.
We have n over log n
bits overall, which
is slightly little o of n.
And that's the bound
we're going to achieve.
OK.
Of course, now we have to solve
the problem within a chunk.
But we've at least reduced to
something of size log squared.
Unfortunately, we need
something of size 1/2 log n
before we can use
a lookup table.
So there's a bit of
a gap here, so we're
going to use indirection
a second time.
This time, we can go all
the way to 1/2 log n.
So I'll use red vertical
bars to denote the subchunks.
Each of these is 1/2 log n.
Overall size of a chunk
here is log squared n.
So every one of these
chunks gets further divided.
Now, how could this help?
Why didn't I just subdivide
into chunks of size 1/2 log n
before?
I mean, why I couldn't
do it is clear.
If I did n over log n of them,
each of them stores log n bits,
I'd have a linear
number of bits.
I can't afford a
linear number of bits.
That would only be
compact, not succinct.
How does it help me to
first reduce to this
and then reduce to this?
Well, what I want to do at
each of these red vertical bars
is store the cumulative
rank, but not
the overall cumulative rank.
I only need the cumulative
rank within the overall chunk,
not relative to
the entire array.
Why does that help me?
AUDIENCE: Need less bits.
ERIK DEMAINE: Need less bits.
These ranks can't get too
big, because the overall size
of a chunk is just log squared.
Log of log squared is log log n.
So I only need log log
n bits to write down
those cumulative ranks.
And so total size
here is going to be
n over log n times
log log n bits,
because there's n over log n
of these red vertical bars.
Each one I only need to
write log log n bits.
And this is slightly
little o of n.
It's actually a little
bit bigger than this,
but still little of of n.
So we can still afford this.
And now we're done, because
these subchunks are of size 1/2
log n, so I can use this lookup
table and solve my problem.
So let me step forward, just
putting everything together.
To compute the rank of a
query, first thing you do
is figure out which chunk you
fall into, which you can do
by division, integer division.
These things are stored in an
array, so you just compute,
what is that cumulative rank?
So you take the
rank of that chunk,
you add on the rank of the
subchunk within the chunk,
and then you add on the rank
of the element in the subchunk.
So rank of the chunk is stored
in the array known as 2.
The rank of the subchunk
within the chunk
is stored in the array,
in the array known as 3.
And then to compute the rank
of the element in the subchunk,
you use the lookup table,
which is essentially
telling you for every possible
subchunk what the answers are.
So 3 times a constant
is a constant.
And we get rank, constant
time, and n log log
n over log n space.
If you're concerned that n
times log log n over log n
is not very sublinear, you
can do a little bit better
using fancier tricks.
Namely, you can achieve n
over log to the kn space.
This is the result of
Patrascu from 2008.
I'm not going to go
into how it's done.
But if you're interested,
it's a little bit less.
It would be nice to do better.
But my guess is there
should be a lower
bounds, that with constant--
so this is for any constant k.
It would be nice to do
better, like square root of n
or something.
But my guess is there's
a matching lower bound.
I don't think that's known.
OK.
So that was rank.
Our next challenge is to
do select, the inverse.
And select is a little
bit harder, I would say.
Don't have a great
intuition why.
But it is.
And we're going to be able to
use the same kind of technique.
So again, we can use
a lookup table and--
I'll do that first.
So just like before, if we have
bit strings of length at most
1/2 log n, then we're only
going to need something
like root n space.
It's root n again times
log n log log n space, just
like rank.
There are at most n possible
queries, actually fewer,
because there may
be fewer 1 bits.
But at most, there
are n 1 bits to query.
An answer is now an index, which
is within a thing of size 1/2
log n.
So I just have to write
down an index of that size,
Soit's it's log log n
bits to write it down.
Cool.
So that's the same.
Now the challenge is about
getting down to 1/2 log n bits.
We're going to use
the same technique
of two levels of indirection.
But they work differently.
There's an extra thing we
need to deal with in select.
There will be two cases,
depending on whether your array
has lots of 1's or
not so many 1's.
And those two cases can
vary throughout the string.
So what we do,
first of all, is--
actually, maybe
I'll go over here.
I'll stick here.
Whatever.
So we're back to
an n-bit string.
So we're looking at we want
the analog of this structure,
this structure of chunks.
Now, we can't just say,
oh, take the bit string,
divide it into
chunks of equal size,
because then given a query,
we want to do select of j,
we need to know which of
these chunks j belongs to.
So instead of making
them equal size,
we're going to make them have
an equal number of 1 bits.
So then we can
just take j, divide
by the size of these chunks,
which is log n log log n.
You could probably do
log squared as well,
but log n log log n is a
slightly better choice.
And so we just divide
every log n log log n
1 bit, put a vertical bar.
That way, given j, we
divide by this thing,
take the floor, that tells
us which chunk we belong to.
So it's different.
Decomposing by 1 space
instead of 01 space.
And so for those guys,
we just store an array.
If your query happens
to have a 0 mod this,
then you have your answer.
Otherwise, you still need
to query within the chunk.
In some sense, the array has
gotten divided something like
this, so the number of 1 bits
in here is always the same,
log n log log n 1's.
So you can now teleport
to the appropriate chunk.
And the issue is, how
do I solve a chunk?
But now chunks have
different sizes,
which is kind of annoying.
That's why we need
this extra step, which
is within a group of
log n log log n 1 bits--
I'm calling them groups
now, instead of chunks.
So each of these groups
has different size.
Let's suppose it has size
r, so say it's r bits long.
R is going to be
different for each chunk,
but we'll do this for
every chunk, every group.
Then there's two cases.
If r is big, we're done.
How big?
Well, if it's at least the
square of the number of 1 bits,
that means it's very sparse.
Only square root of
the bits are 1's.
The rest are all 0's.
But then, I can afford to
just store all the answers.
I'm just going to store a
lookup table of all the answers
if it's very sparse,
because then I
claim I only need this
many bits in order
to store all of these answers.
So if I do this
for all groups that
have a large number of bits,
I store this lookup array,
how many--
if I sum up the size
of all of these arrays,
how much do I pay?
Well, the lookup array
has this kind of size.
There are log n
log log n 1 bits.
And each of them I need to
store an index for them.
Now, this could cost log n
bits, because potentially one
of these groups is very large.
It could be almost linear size.
So I need log n bits to write
down a position in there.
There's log n log log n 1 bits
to write down to position for.
So this is the size of
one of these arrays.
Now, how many of these could
I possibly need to store?
Well, I know that this
group has log n log log
n squared bits in it, so the
maximum number of such groups
is n over that, n over
log n log log n squared.
And now we get to do
some cancellation.
So this 2 cancels with
this log n log log n.
And then this log n
cancels with this log n.
And so we get n over
log log n bits, which
is slightly little of of n.
OK.
Again, it is possible to get
n over log to the k space.
But we won't do that here.
We'll be happy enough
with n over log log n.
OK.
But we're not done,
unfortunately.
So we've now reduced
in two groups,
and I've only
given you one case.
This is when r is large.
The other cases, r
is small, meaning
the number of bits in the group
is at most log n log log n
squared.
That's a good case
for us, because that's
pretty similar to rank.
Here we got chunks
of size log squared.
Here it's slightly
larger than log squared,
but only by a poly
log log factor.
And that would correspond
to this step 2 in rank.
You do step 2 and step 3 here.
Then we get step 2 of rank.
We've reduced to
poly log size chunks
by getting rid of this case.
And so we have to do it again,
because we have poly log
size groups.
But we need to get down to
groups of size log, 1/2 log.
So we need to do another
layer of indirection.
So we get to do
steps 2 and 3 again.
This is what I'll call step 4.
Repeat steps 2 and 3 on--
oh, sorry.
I didn't say I need
an else clause.
Else I'm going to call this bit
vector a reduced bit vector.
So I've reduced to order log
n log log n squared bits.
And so step 4 is on
all reduced strings,
all reduced bit strings.
I want to do steps
2 and 3 again.
Let me do it quickly.
My goal is to further
reduce to poly log log n.
I took n bit strings and I
got down to log poly log bits.
I do it again, I should get
down to poly log log bits.
And indeed, I can.
And this is plenty small.
Poly log log is way
smaller than 1/2 log,
so we don't even need that
much of the lookup table.
Fine.
So I'll call this 2 prime.
I want to make this
explicit, because they
are slightly different,
because now everything's
relative to the reduced
string, which is poly log.
This gets hard to pronounce,
but every log log n square-th 1
bit, we're going to write
down the relative index
within the reduced
string of size log n.
So writing down
the relative index
only costs log log n
bits, because we're
in something of size
log n, so writing down
that index is short.
We write it down
for all of these,
so we end up paying n
over log log n squared.
That's the maximum
number of these indices
that we need to store.
Each of them we pay log log n.
So here I'm summing over
all the reduced bit strings.
This is an overall size.
It's at most n over log log n
squared that we need to store.
Could be fewer if there aren't
many reduced bit strings.
But worst case, everything
ends up being reduced,
so we have this many times
that many times that many bits.
And we get n over
log log n bits.
This is roughly following the
pattern of step 2 over here.
Step 2 over here didn't
just have the log term.
It also had an
auxiliary log log term.
So if you felt like it,
you could make this log
log n times log log log n.
But it will actually give
you worse space bound,
so this is slightly better.
OK.
Then we apply step
3 prime, which
is we look at each of the
groups that we've identified.
And either it's big and
it has lots of 0 bits,
or it's not big.
And in either case,
we're going to be happy.
So if a group of log log n
squared 1 bits has r bits,
we look at each of
them individually.
And if r is at least
the square of that,
so log log n to
the fourth power--
so we're losing constants
in the exponents,
but it's not a big deal--
then store relative--
I mean, store all the answers,
but now as relative indices.
OK.
Let's go over here.
So how much do these
relative indices cost?
Again, it's at most order log
log n bits to write them down.
We don't know that a group
is any smaller than log n,
but it's at most the
original size of log n.
It's only log log n bits
to write each of them down.
And now we get to
say, oh, well, we
had to write down log
log n squared 1 bits.
But this can only
happen n over log log n
to the fourth many times.
So the space is n over
log log n to the fourth.
That's the maximum
number of these
I guess you call them sparse
bit vectors, sparse groups there
could be, because each of
them is at least this big.
The total number of them is
at most n divided by that.
For each of them, we
have to write down
log log n squared different
indices for our array.
And each of those indices cost
log log n bits to write down.
So this is log log n
to the third power.
This is log log n
to the fourth power.
So again, this is
n over log log n.
You can tell I've tuned
all of these numbers
to come out to n
over log log n bits.
OK.
That was the if case.
There's the else case, which
is that you have reduced
to poly log log size, namely
then in the dense case,
you have r is at most
log log n to the fourth.
So at this point, else
you are further reduced.
When you're further reduced,
you have at most log log n
to the fourth bits.
And at most, log log n
squared of them are 1 bits.
But we don't really
care about that.
Once we're down to a bit
vector of poly log log size,
we can use our lookup
table and we're done.
So that's select.
If you want to do a
select on an index,
first you figure
out which group it's
in by dividing by log n log
log n, taking the floor.
You teleport to the appropriate
group using this array.
Then within that group,
there's a bit saying
whether it was sparse or dense.
If it was sparse, so
lots of 0's in it,
then you have a lookup table
that gives you all your answers
for the remainder of your query.
If it's dense, then
you go over here.
You know that this
thing will be stored,
and so you figure
out which subgroup
you belong to by
dividing by log log n
squared, taking the floor.
There's an array,
this thing, that
teleports you to that group--
sorry, to that subgroup.
And then you apply--
then there's a bit there saying
whether it was sparse or dense.
If it was sparse, there's
a lookup table giving you
the answer.
If it was dense, there's an
index into the number 1 lookup
table that tells
you what this bit
string is, because there is only
log log n to the fourth bits.
In fact, that is the index.
Just what those bits are lets
you look up into this table
and solve your query in
constant time, in all cases
constant time.
But here's a little
bit more branching,
depending on your situation.
As I said, select is a little
more complicated than rank.
But in the end,
constant time, little
of of n space, n over log
log n, which can again
be improved by
Patrascu, n over log
to the k for any constant k.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Can you just quickly
remind us how the 2 and 3
changed [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: OK.
How did 2 and 3 change?
You don't actually really
need to change them.
The big change is that you're
storing only relative indices,
not indices.
So before, we were storing
an array of indices
of every log log nth 1 bit.
These were global pointers.
But now after 2 and 3,
we've reduced to something
of size log n or poly log n.
We need to exploit that
here, so that we were only
storing log log n bits.
If we didn't do that,
this would be order n bits
and it would be too big.
That's really the only
thing you need to change.
The other thing I
changed was this value.
If you follow that
plan, it would be--
it was also a square.
So we did have to
add a square here.
You could also add a
log log log n term here,
but it won't matter.
Basically you do
something that works.
The square was necessary
to cancel out this guy,
for example.
If you didn't do the square--
well, so instead
of this, you could
have done log log n times log
log log n without the square.
Then here you would have
gotten n over log log log n.
So you could have
followed the same pattern.
You'd just get a slightly
worse space bound.
I tuned it here.
Here we needed--
here we could not
have afforded to
go to log squared,
if I recall correctly,
though you can check that.
Maybe it's a good pset question.
There's lots of
choices that work here.
But this is the one I
find the cleanest that
gets a decent bound, not the
best bound, but reasonable.
Other questions?
I think that's all
that I changed.
The sparsity definition
was still a squared thing,
so it was squared over here
and it was squared over here.
It's just the thing
we were squaring
was a little different.
OK.
One more thing I
want to talk about.
So at this point, we just finish
this level order representation
of binary tries,
because we already
saw left child, right
child, and parent,
reduced to rank and select.
We just solved rank and
select in little o of n bits,
so at least statically
we can do left child,
right child, parent
in a binary try now
in constant time per
operation, 2n plus little
o of n bits of space.
The 2n bits are to
store those 2n bits
that we wrote down before.
So that's succinct binary tries.
Done.
One mention, there are
some dynamic versions.
In particular, there are dynamic
versions of rank and select.
But the best versions that
are known to do dynamic rank
and select achieve
something like log over log
log time per operation, if
you're interested in dynamic.
So this is kind of annoying.
If you want to go to dynamic,
either you pay more time
or you don't use
rank and select.
But I'm not going to worry
too much about dynamic.
Stick to rank and select.
But there's one more
thing on this list,
which is a different way to
do succinct binary tries.
And this different way is
going to be more powerful, more
useful for things like
suffix trees, which is what
we're going to do next class.
So I want to tell you a
little bit about this.
The level order representation
is kind of like a warm-up.
It motivates rank and select.
But it does not let
us do subtree size.
Subtree size would
be nice to do,
because you care about
how many matches you have
after you do a search
down a suffix tree.
Level order just ain't
going to cut it for that,
so we're going to use
different representation.
We're still going to use
rank and select a lot.
And I'll generalize
forms of rank and select.
But it's going to be a
little bit more handy.
Essentially I want to do more
like a depth-first search
of the try, less like a--
less level order,
so more depth-first.
OK.
Here's our friend the binary
try, same one as before.
We had our binary
representation of it.
I'm not going to draw that here.
First thing I want to
do is say, hey, look,
this is the same thing
as a rooted ordered tree.
I already mentioned that
there's the same number of them.
There's Catalan of these and
there's Catalan of these.
So a rooted ordered
tree has a node,
it has some number of
children, then more nodes.
The children are ordered, but
they don't have labels on them.
So it's a tree, not a try.
So I claim these two
things are equivalent.
And there's a nice combinatorial
bijection between them,
which you may have seen before.
It's kind of a classic.
But here we're going to
use it for handy stuff.
Basically so binary
tries distinguish
between left and right.
Rooted order trees do not.
They just have order.
So to clean that up,
I'm going to look
at the right spine of the try,
distinguish that, because right
and left make the difference
here, and then recurse.
So this is the right
spine of down here.
This is the right
spine of this subtree.
Now every node lives
in some right spine.
And then I'm just
going to rotate
45 degrees counterclockwise.
So I have A, E, G. That's
my first right spine.
I'm going to think of them as
children of a new root node.
And then they have
children below that
which correspond to the
right spines that hang below.
So A, for example, has
this right spine, B, C, D.
So we have B, C, D here.
E has a right spine of
F hanging off of it.
G has no right spine
hanging off of it.
So you need to prove that
this is a real bijection.
Every binary try
can be so converted
into a rooted order tree.
And it's unique, so if
it's different over here,
it will be different over here.
And you can convert
backwards as well,
if you just delete
the super-root
and turn all the children
into a right spine or recurse.
They're really the same thing.
This is why there's
Catalan of each of them.
OK.
Now what I'd really like to
get to is balanced parentheses.
And while it's a
little unclear how
to represent a binary try
with balanced parentheses,
these things it's really clear
how to represent a binary--
represent with
balanced parentheses.
Here I just do an
Euler tour, which
was a depth-first search
visiting these things.
And every time I start a node,
I'll write an open paren.
Every time I finish a node,
I write a close paren.
Similar to representation
we talked about before.
So this would be--
I'm going to need more space.
This is going to be an
open paren for star.
Why don't I make
that one really big?
We start here.
Then we open the A chunk.
Then we do B, which
has no children.
Then we do C, which
Then we do D, which
has no children.
And that finishes A.
OK.
Then we start E.
Then we do F. Then
we finish F. We finish
E. Then we do G.
And then we're done with star.
So that's a very
easy transformation.
Again, there are Catalan many
of these balanced parens.
You think, oh, there's
2 to the n of them,
because each paren
could be open or closed.
But they have to be balanced,
so it's a little bit more
constrained than that.
And so it ends up being
Catalan of n over 2
if there's n parens, because
there's 2 parens here
for every node over here.
This is going to
be our bit string.
Open parens are 0's.
Close parens are 1's.
This has roughly 2n bits, 2n
plus 2, I guess, for the star,
relative to this n.
So basically, nodes
here correspond
to nodes here, which correspond
to an open paren, close paren
pair over here.
Now, we can't afford
to store these labels.
Those are just guidelines to
think about what you need.
So let's think about there
are three things we really
want here, left child,
right child, and parent.
This is the thing
that we care about,
but this is what
we're going to store.
So I want to translate
from here to here to here.
This is an exercise
in translation.
So what does a left
child mean here?
Left child over here
corresponds to--
well, I guess it goes--
in general, the left child
goes to this branch, which
is like all of these
children pointers from A.
But really, if you
follow the left child,
you get to B, not any
of the other things
on the right spine.
You always get to the
top of the right spine.
Top of the right spine is the
left-most node in the spine
here.
In other words, it is the
first child of a node.
First child of a
node, if there is one,
is going to be the
left child over here.
Right child is like
following the spine.
That's like going this way.
So right child is what I
would call next sibling.
The next sibling to the
right, if there is one,
that's going to correspond
to the right child,
because we're just
following a right spine.
OK.
Parent is a little trickier.
Parent is the reverse
of these, so either you
take your previous sibling--
but if you're here and there
is no previous sibling,
then you take your
actual parent,
because parent
should walk up here.
This was like going
left, previous sibling,
previous sibling.
Parent of this guy, though, is
the actual parent over here.
So this is going to be previous
sibling if there is one,
or if there isn't one,
you go to the parent.
OK.
So that's easy translation.
Now we need to
convert these pictures
into balanced parentheses
pictures, which is also
going to be easy in itself.
But to jump all the way from
binary tries to balanced parens
would be pretty
confusing, so that's why
we have this intermediate step.
So we want first child here.
If I have a paren-- like I'm
looking at A. So A corresponds
to this paren and this paren.
I'm going to represent the node
let's say by the first paren.
Then the first child is just
the very next character.
You put the first child
right after that open paren.
So this is really
the next character
if we want to find
the first child.
This is if it's an open paren.
It could be the very next--
like if you're doing B,
the very next character
is a close paren, that
means there are no children.
But that's how you can tell
whether there's a child.
If there's an open paren
right after your open paren,
that's your next child.
That's your first
child, I should say.
Now what about next sibling?
So let's say again
I'm at A. And I
want to know the next sibling.
Next sibling is E.
So that's like I
go to the close paren
for A, and then I
go to the next character.
So this would be go to the close
paren for where you are right
now, and then go to
the next character.
This is, again, if
it's an open paren.
If it's a close paren, then
you have no next sibling.
So again, you can tell
whether this operation fails.
What we need is an operation
given a bit string representing
balanced parentheses and given a
query position of a left paren,
I need to know what is
the matching right paren.
And I'll just wave
my hands and claim
that can be done with the same
techniques as rank and select.
It's not easy.
It's quite a bit harder.
But you do enough
of these recursions,
eventually you can solve it.
OK.
Last operation is
parent over here,
which corresponds
to previous sibling,
or parent over here,
which corresponds to--
there are two cases.
We want to move backwards,
so here we're always
ending with next character.
So first thing we do is go
to the previous character.
And there are two cases.
If it's a close paren--
so let's say we're here at E,
we go to the previous character.
If it's a close paren, then
A is our previous sibling,
and so we want to do the
previous sibling situation.
We again find the match.
We hit percent and vi and--
what's the corresponding
thing in Emacs?
I forget.
You go to the
matching close paren--
sorry, open paren.
And then there you go.
You've got your
previous sibling.
So if it's a close
paren, then you
go to the corresponding
open paren.
If the previous character is an
open paren, then you're done.
That's your parent.
So like here if you're at A,
you go to the previous character
and it's open paren, then you've
just found the parent of A.
There was no previous sibling.
So in either case you end
up with an open paren,
corresponding to either
your previous sibling
or your parent.
So that's left child,
right child, parent.
If you have this
matching paren operation,
you can do all of
these in constant time,
and little of n space
beyond the 2n bits
to write down that bit string.
That's not so exciting,
because we just
reinvented the same
results we had before
of doing left, right, and
parent in constant time.
But what we buy out
of this representation
is we can now do subtree size.
So this is a little
bit trickier.
Let me go to another board.
But whereas with
level representation
it was impossible,
now it is possible.
And we're going to use subtree
size I think next class, when
we do compact suffix trees.
So subtree size is what
we want in the binary try.
In the rooted ordered
tree it's a little tricky,
because subtrees no longer
correspond to subtrees.
For example, the
subtree of C consists
of this subtree and this
subtree, so it's really C--
over here, it's C and all
of its right siblings.
So this is size of the node
plus size of right siblings,
however many you have.
OK.
So in the rooted ordered tree,
it's actually kind of messy.
Turns out in the
balanced parenthesis
it's pretty clean,
because all your right
siblings correspond
to paren groups
that just follow each other.
And you want to know--
so these are a bunch of
siblings here of varying size.
And we're given,
say, this sibling.
We want to know
for this sibling,
up to all the ones to
the right-- so there's
an enclosing parenthesis
here for our parent
in this representation.
We want to know the length
of these, so it's just--
we want to take the-- here
we are at this left paren.
We want to compute the distance
to the enclosing close paren.
So that's here.
That's our enclosing
close paren.
So here's a new operation.
Given a paren pair, I want to
compute the enclosing paren
pair, these guys.
That can also be done
in constant time with
rank-and-select-like techniques.
And then you just measure this
distance and you divide by 2.
That will give you the
number of nodes in here.
It's half the number of paren.
That will give you subtree size.
And we have a couple
extra seconds,
so another bonus
is suppose you want
to know the number of
leaves in a subtree.
If I recall correctly,
that's something like--
instead of doing this distance
to the enclosing paren,
you do something like rank of--
just rank of that.
Those are the number of leaves
of the enclosing close paren--
this is getting
notationally confusing--
minus the rank of here.
OK.
So I just want to compute how
many open parens, close parens
are there from here to here.
And so I just take the rank
here, subtract by the rank
here.
That gives me the number
of leaves in that range.
So this is a
generalization of rank.
Before we did rank
of just a single bit.
This is rank of a
two-bit pattern.
But two bits is not much
harder than one bit.
You can very easily
adapt the rank structure
we saw to do any two-bit pattern
instead of just the one bit.
So that gives you
the number of leaves
in the subtree,
which corresponds
to the number of matches.
So you can do lots of
fun things like this.
This representation
is super powerful
and we'll use it next time.